Welcome, everybody. Special welcome to all of
our new audio podcast subscribers, Record Week.
Yesterday was the best day the audio podcast
has ever had. Unbelievable. And want to
welcome everybody who is carrying the show
around with them in their pocket, I guess,
as I call it. We have so much to talk about.
And because there's been so much to talk about,
we really have not spent as much time
as we should be spending on coronavirus.
And I would be doing a disservice to you
if I didn't do that today. And remember,
Donald Trump said that there would be no more
talk of coronavirus on November 4th because it
was merely political. Trump said everything was
going to open on November 4th. Trump said there
would be no more discussions of an urgent pandemic
on November 4th. Of course, it's been the exact
opposite, in fact. And Joe Biden has fortunately
immediately formed a coronavirus taskforce which
has already met. We have continued to talk about
it, and coronavirus is completely out of control.
There's there's no other way to say it. It's
completely outrageous dystopia numbers when
you look at them and this administration
has done so. Our approach going in is
if we don't do something and if governors don't
do something until Joe Biden is inaugurated,
Trump is done. Trump is in a fragile emotional
state. As Philip Rucker will later tell us, he
is done with the virus now. Meanwhile, the United
States hit a record number of hospitalizations
this week. We passed one million new cases in just
ten days, the first 10 days of November. This is
exploding and the first two spikes in April
and July. When you look at a case graph,
they barely even look like spikes. The
current third spike during which we're seeing
even one hundred and forty thousand new
cases per day makes those early spikes in
April and July look like little molehills. And
of course, they were major spikes at the time.
And Dr. Anthony Fauci warned us about this
months ago. Dr. Fauci said you could see
100000 cases a day in the fall. And when we got
to 35000 in April and they started declining,
a lot of people didn't believe Dr. Fauci,
but he was right. And if anything, he wasn't
aggressive enough because we are seeing
one hundred and forty thousand per day,
no sign of a slowdown. Deaths are also spiking.
We've now had two days in a row with right around
1500 deaths per day. That's a 9/11 every two
days. And those numbers are going to go higher.
Deaths today, remember, are based on cases two
to three weeks ago, two to three weeks ago,
we had half the cases that we do
today. So in two to three more weeks,
we could be seeing 2500 deaths a day.
We could be seeing 3000 deaths a day.
Not out of the question. We could be seeing a 9/11
every single day. Right now, 49 out of 50 states
are increasing in cases. 30 states set new records
just this week. And like I said, hospitalization.
There were a couple of weeks. There were cases
were going up. Hospitalizations were not yet up.
Hospitalizations have now reached a pandemic
high and are clearly going higher since 140000
more people tested positive yesterday and the day
before in. I'm trying to think what state it was.
I believe it's in one of the Dakotas. The governor
has announced that it must be it must be North
Dakota because South Dakota's Kristi Noem and this
was a male governor, I believe it's the governor
of North Dakota. I should be more prepared. I'm
going from memory said hospitals are now full and
they are going to need nurses to keep working even
if they have coronavirus nurses with coronavirus
in again, I believe it's is North Dakota have
been cleared to keep working even when they test
positive, because things are that out of control.
We need leadership. I know it's easy to say.
Listen, David, every country is having a spike.
Every country is seeing a spike. Remember that
many countries are on Spike, too, right now.
So when we look at other countries and we see
they are also having record numbers, they are
having record numbers related to spike number one.
Many of those countries suppress the second spike
all summer and they are now getting to the second
spike. We're already on spike number three and
spike number three is putting Spike number two
to shame. All these other countries are only
now getting to Spike number two. And when we
say everything is spiking, understand that we are
a I'm not calling them Wavves because we never
really got out of wave one. But spikes, we are a
full spike ahead of most of these countries and it
is an absolute and total disaster. CDC now issuing
recommendations about Thanksgiving and those
recommendations are. Have Thanksgiving outside
now in much of the country. It's not possible the
Dakotas, Minnesota, northern Michigan, you know,
it gets very, very cold here in Massachusetts.
It may well be a high of 30 by the time of
Thanksgiving, even though it's been unseasonably
warm. So a lot of people I know are either not
doing Thanksgiving or they are doing a drastically
reduced Thanksgiving. I know a few folks who said
we were doing like a six person Thanksgiving.
And what we've agreed to do is everybody's
getting tested on Monday of Thanksgiving week,
doing nothing for the rest of the week.
And assuming we all get negative tests,
we'll do an indoor thing, hopefully with
windows open sitting far apart on Thursday.
Thanksgiving has the remember, we didn't have
Thanksgiving during the pandemic last year and
Thanksgiving could be a real super spreader
event nationally. I think I'm doing nothing
on Thanksgiving. That's the latest for me.
I think I will be reading and catching up
on some documentaries that I've been I've been
meaning to, but it is looking very, very ugly.